[Music]
do
[Music]
do
[Music]
welcome everyone i hope everyone's doing
well
thanks for uh joining us on this friday
morning at least here in the east coast
of the united states a little bit early
for me i
i like to sleep a little later but this
is the time that it worked out
best for all involved as you know today
we're having a conversation with
nobel laureate frank wilcheck has made
tremendously profound contributions to
our understanding
of physics in a variety of arenas you
know some people make a contribution in
just one
area and they do something that catches
the community of physicists catches
their attention
sets the world on fire in this case wins
a nobel prize and then just dig
deeper in that area but that's not frank
wilczak frank a very broad thinker
is willing to take on a whole slew of
different problems and has had made
because i have made great contributions
right across the board we're going to
talk about
a variety of things particle physics
some cosmology but also want to spend
some time talking about
his new book we can actually bring the
cover of that up for a teaser if you
will
it's new book it's called fundamentals
10 keys to reality
just read it it's a beautifully written
new book so we'll talk about some of the
ideas that frank
puts forward in that but before we get
to that
let's start as we always do with some of
your questions a little bit of round
up on some of the important ideas
that people are discussing debating
these days let me just see if there's
anything in the chat that
catches my attention
ah tanzu tanzu asks what do you think
about the hierarchy problem the
hierarchy problem
hierarchy problem is um it's actually
relevant to what we'll be talking today
in some sense
with frank but the hierarchy problem is
this fact
that when you look at the various mass
scales
in particle physics the masses of the
fundamental constituents
and you compare that to the fundamental
scale
that emerges from the understanding of
the strengths
of forces the strength of gravity and
the various constants of nature there's
a
a big spread in scales you no doubt have
heard of the planck mass
planck mass is a is a is a numerical
number in the units of mass that
naturally emerges by a particular
combination
of planck's constant the gravitational
constant speed of light you put them
together
in the right configuration and you get
something with the units of a mass and
the particular amount of mass
is about 10 to the 19 times the mass of
the proton
10 to the 19. that's huge right so
so the fundamental mass scale that seems
to emerge
from our description of the forces
of nature and quantum mechanics speed of
light gravity and so forth
that number is 10 billion
billion times larger than the scale
of masses that we actually see in the
particles in the world around us so the
question is
why is there such a broad spread of
scales
and we've been trying to come to grips
with that
problem for a very long time
the idea of supersymmetry that some of
you may have heard of this idea that for
every known particle there's a partner
particle whose quantum mechanical spin
would be different in slightly technical
language
that idea was partly introduced
to deal with this hierarchy problem
the quality of those partner particles
within the theoretical framework
allows for a very natural explanation
for why
the particles would have such a low mass
it all comes down to a symmetry
principle whenever a number is really
small
a natural explanation is well it must be
small because
some kind of symmetry keeps it small i
mean
zero is the most symmetric number we
know you multiply it by
anything you divide it by anything it
stays the same
symmetry is a quality of a system that
is unchanged under a whole variety of
transformations
right you take a sphere you rotate it
if it's a nice silver sphere without
anything printed on the surface
no matter what angle you look at that
sphere no matter how you twist it and
turn it the sphere looks the same it is
highly symmetric
similarly the number zero is highly
symmetric as i said you multiply divide
doesn't change so if you can find a
symmetry that naturally
yields zero mass for the particles then
you set yourself well
maybe that's why they're so small and
maybe that symmetry is not exact
maybe that symmetry is almost but not
quite
an exact quality of
the world the environment and that would
allow the masses to be
near zero but not exactly zero and
this is this approach that supersymmetry
gives us so
the problem of course is no one's found
the supersymmetric particles
large hazron collider the hope was that
it would
find all sorts of other particles that
we hadn't previously seen partners of
the electron called the supersymmetric
electron or this electron
partners of the corks we'll talk about
quarks today with frank no doubt that's
where
a lot of his profound contributions have
been made squirks would be the super
symmetric
partners of the quarks look i don't need
i don't name these things sounds a
little silly
but this is a real mathematical theory
and look a
10 billion dollar machine was built in
part to try to find the supersymmetric
particles
and it's been disappointing that we
haven't found
these particles is it surprising well
we never knew the energy scale
the size of the machine therefore
necessary to conjure these new particles
out of the void you know equals m t
squared we'll talk about this also a
little bit later
you can read that as m equals z over c
squared right so mass can come from
energy so you have highly energetic
particles colliding and that energy can
be transformed
into mass into new particles and the
hope was by slamming protons together at
the large hadron collider with
sufficient energy
we'd be able to convert that energy into
the mass
of these never bore never before seen
particles
didn't happen or it hasn't happened may
still happen maybe you need a more
powerful machine
maybe their masses are are larger than
we can conjure
out of the vacuum out of the void so
the hierarchy problem and this idea of
supersymmetry is a possible solution
still
up in the air not as not as favored as
it once was i mean when i was a graduate
student
i don't know it was almost a foregone
conclusion that the world was going to
be super symmetric that we would find
these supersymmetric particles almost
every paper that i've written that's
maybe a little exaggeration but
the vast majority of papers that i've
written in one way or another have
supersymmetry at their core
and some of the papers that i've written
are using supersymmetry as a
mathematical tool
and as a mathematical tool it's
unassailable right it's a piece of
mathematics it doesn't matter
whether the world makes use of this
quality when you're doing mathematics
you don't
have the constraints of nature breathing
down your neck
you can just do mathematics that's one
of the
beauties but also one of the pitfalls of
mathematics i mean
the reason why i personally shifted my
focus to physics when i was quite young
it felt to me that the problems of
mathematics were
just too artificial in a sense
i don't know if that's exactly the right
word they were too lenient maybe that's
a better way of putting it i liked the
idea
of doing mathematics with the goal
of aligning it with qualities of the
physical world
but nevertheless math on its own
is enriching fun gratifying and
supersymmetry has had a powerful
impact in our understanding of
mathematics but as a tool to understand
the physical world
yeah that's still that is still somewhat
up
in the air someone else mentioned
something in the
questions here which i caught my eye i
don't know sorry i can't give your name
it's somewhere in the
in the chat there but asked about the
this thing called the hubble tension
you guys heard of this the hubble
tension this is this
state of affairs right now where
our measurements of the expansion rate
of space the expansion of the universe
have become so
precise that
when we find discrepancies between
distinct ways of
measuring the expansion rate of space
we have to start to take those
discrepancies really seriously and ask
yourself
whether we are missing something i mean
right big bang right space i think we
have a little
little visual on that it's always nice
to start the morning off with a bit of a
cosmological explosion so if we can
bring up
that animation on the screen yeah so you
know the big bang
things start tightly compressed this
rapid swelling
yeah it's just a artist rendition but
you see that
everything expands outward space itself
is swelling
and the question is how fast is it
swelling and there are there are a
number of ways that we can
get at that answer one way is very
direct
you look at distant objects like
supernova explosions
and based upon the redshift of the light
that they emit
right the light that they emit travels
across space as space is
swelling it stretches the wavelength
of the light that's called red shifting
and the degree of redshifting is
something that we can measure
because we know the processes that are
happening in that system
we know the light that we would receive
from it if it was sitting right next to
us
and when we look at the light we
actually receive it's not that light
it's stretched out
versions of that light but we can
measure the amount of stretching
and the amount of stretching gives us
insight
into the rate at which space
is expanding so that's one way of
measuring these things another way is
you look at the cosmic microwave
background radiation this heat left over
from the big bang and by carefully
measuring it
you can build up confidence in an
inventory of the things that are filling
space the amount of matter
the amount of dark matter energy dark
energy
and using those insights you can then
predict
from those measurements the rate of
spatial expansion
it turns out that those two approaches
give different answers not hugely
different but different enough
that they are in tension right edwin
hubble
is the person who found through
observations of distant galaxies that
space is expanding
so the tension is called the hubble
tension it's not like a literal tension
sometimes we do talk about tension in
physics and we'll talk about tension
later on
tension between two quarks we'll talk
about we'll get to that
but this is more a metaphorical
tension in that these two measurements
don't seem to agree
so what's the answer i don't know nobody
does really there are interesting
proposals that people put forward
that maybe there's a kind of ingredient
that was present in the early universe
that gave the universe a kind of boost
in its expansion relative to what we
would have thought
and this ingredient we don't see it
today the theory goes because it may
have
decayed it may have
drifted back to emptiness over time
so
the fairly significant rewriting of our
thinking
about the cosmological progression
but who knows others you know the more
conservative
approaches some will say it's going to
go away this tension
these two measurements you know these
measurements are difficult
and over time they have certainly
bounced around
but others say you know we've really
gotten to a level of sophistication
in our theoretical understanding and our
mathematical predictions
in our observations from a whole variety
of different
sources ground-based telescopes space
based telescopes right and
some would say the level of
sophistication and refinement in all
of those ingredients are such that when
there is a discrepancy
in two approaches that are trying to get
at the same number
the rate of spatial expansion you've got
to take it seriously so people are
taking it seriously
and we'll just have to see where that
where that all goes as we head forward
all right before i bring frank wilcheck
in about 10 minutes i thought it'd be
nice to just spend
a little bit of time you know five ten
minutes
talking about what it is that he won the
nobel
prize for no doubt we'll talk about this
again i think it's always kind of nice
on these subtle ideas to see it twice
leisurely with me maybe more rapidly
with our illustrious guest so frank
i think he was i have to ask him i think
he was in his early 20s
when he wrote a paper with david gross
another nobel prize winning visit they
shared the prize i don't know if we have
a
copy of that paper we can bring up on
the screen it's just short
paper you know many nobel prize winning
papers are
are quite short you don't have to write
a big dissertation a big tone
to make an impact so this is the first
page just a few pages i don't know how
many is maybe three or four pages in
total
yeah they're coming up on the screen
here it's a handful of
pages and what they did in this paper
was to
give a mathematical derivation
that aligned with puzzling observations
what did the puzzling observation had to
do with
quarks and the observations seem to
suggest
that when quarks are
in the vicinity of one another when
they're very close
the strong nuclear force that's what
holds
protons together the strong nuclear
force gets
very weak when the particles are very
near each other and it goes stronger and
stronger as you move them
apart like that's unusual right
i mean if you talk about the
gravitational force gravitational force
though very
very strong when things are close and it
gets weak as you move them apart
quite the the opposite and
what they showed was that when you take
certain quantum mechanical effects into
account it's as if
the roiling bubbly vacuum of space has
the property
that it kind of
anti-screens the force right normally if
you have bubbly things happening they
can
intervene in the force between two
objects
and make the force between them weaker
but the bubbly stuff it turns out
makes the force stronger and there's
some
the the little formula i think we do
have the formula they derive i don't
know if they have an exactly the form
that's in their paper it's the
so-called beta function
of the strong interactions yeah we won't
get into
the gory details here but that number
alpha in there
that is a measure of the strength of the
strong
interaction and and the beautiful thing
in this formula what really
what wins the nobel prize it turns out
as we'll talk with frank
that minus sign in that formula
in there is the size of the color group
you know it's all technical stuff
nf is the number of flavors the number
of cork species
basically but that minus sign is what
establishes that as you
move quarks closer and closer together
the force gets weak and weaker as you
move them apart it gets
stronger and stronger and this also
gives
an explanation of why one would never
see a quark on its own
why would you never see a quark on its
own i'll show you an animation in a
minute but the basic idea
relies on einstein's equals mc squared
right remember einstein wrote his famous
paper and special relativity in june of
1905
but then in september of 1905 you had an
afterthought
and an additional little paper that
he knocks off i think we have the uh
september paper yeah here it is again
just a
just a few pages and it's in this paper
if we go i think to the very last page
that we have
the formula equals mc squared now
einstein didn't write it
in the form e equals m c squared in
effect he wrote it
in the way that i mentioned before he
divided both sides by
c squared and had m equals e over c
squared now he didn't even use
c for the speed of light to use capital
v a different notation it all means the
same stuff
he didn't use e for the energy it uses l
that we have over here you see it if a
body releases the energy
l and there must be a reason for l i
don't know maybe in german
i i don't know i don't know why i used l
but l over v
squared is the same thing as e over c
squared
so as you see in that line mass is
related
to e over c squared but the point is
forgetting about notation that's sort of
fun
to see ein there's the genesis of the
most famous equation in the world
right that's kind of fun but the point
is
energy and mass are interchangeable so
i'll show you an animation just a second
but let me explain it in words first if
you have two quarks and you try to pull
them apart
the energy of the strong connection
between them from the strong nuclear
force it gets stronger and stronger
more and more attention more and more
energy in there at some point the energy
in the strong connection between them
can be transmuted
into the production of mass namely two
other quarks a quark and an antiquark so
the connection between them can snap
but when it snaps you'll find two more
quarks you won't have pulled
that cork into isolation let's show a
little animation on that i think we have
a little
visual here so we have two quarks that's
a strong force holding them together
more and more tension between them at
some point the energy of the tension is
so strong that
it will snap creating
a cork anti-corp pair so you can't get
the cork in isolation again those
can snap again right
every time you try to pull a cork
by itself you wind up failing
because as you try to pull them apart
the energy ultimately gets transmuted
into the production of a new partner
a new partner cork
this also explains another
issue that no doubt i think we'll talk
about when
frank is here and i think he'll be in
just a moment which is
you know when you talk about a proton
and people have asked this and various
other
other chats that we've had in the past
if you go to a book
and you look up the mass of the quarks
that make up a proton
right the up the down quark you look up
their masses you add them together
basically three quarks inside of a
proton
the answer you get is a tiny fraction
of the mass of a proton itself so what
gives
right we normally think of a proton made
of three quarks add up the masses of the
quarks to get the mass of the proton but
no
you get a tiny fraction of the mass of
the proton
and again the ideas that we're talking
about give
an explanation for that because again
these the glue the gluons of the strong
interaction
that hold the quarks together they have
energy
and indeed if we show up let me show an
atom do we have one
atom show up yeah right so here's an
atom right you got the
electron cloud around the nucleus
there's a proton inside the proton there
goes the quarks but the quarks are held
together by these
energetic tubes of glue the gluons and
they're in a sea
of roiling production of corks
antiquarks and gluons all over the place
and it's the energy and all the other
stuff
that via einstein's m equals e over c
squared contributes the m the mass of
the proton so most of the mass of the
proton is not the
intrinsic mass of the corks most of the
mass
this is other stuff so these are the
ideas
that frank has been so instrumental in
in developing and transforming or
understanding the world i mean look
they're only
there aren't there aren't that many
physicists who actually transform our
understanding of the world
you know einstein was one of them of
course
frank wilceck is on that level so
with that it's my great honor to bring
frank wilcheck into
our conversation i think he is here i'm
told he is here
as we bring him in let me just note that
frank wilcheck is
the hermann feshbach professor of
physics at mit
in 2004 he won the nobel prize
for the discussions and discoveries that
we will be talking about i just made a
reference to
and as i mentioned he has a new book
fundamentals 10
keys to reality and we're gonna get into
that in our conversation today
and as you may no doubt know
i'm now riffing because i have no idea
why frank
isn't up on the screen here i don't see
him
there he is
i enjoyed watching you for a few minutes
there
great to see you frank how's everything
good
very good uh you know in so much as
insofar as it can be good with the world
falling apart
around us i'm actually optimistic about
the
future yeah where are you now are you
concord massachusetts hungary
massachusetts and have you been there
for most of the pandemic
i've been here since mid-march right
yeah right only small
excursions to take walks in the forest
and
historic fights around here yeah for
sure
and i mean what do you what what is your
feeling about what's happening
in i'm not this is not a political talk
show
what's what's your take on what's
happening right now i guess my feeling
is this too shall pass
and if you go if you think
cosmically in terms of scales of space
and time and
and even of human history i
i think there's every reason to be
optimistic about
the future yeah there are dangers
looming uh of course there's the specter
of climate change and nuclear war
and of course the one could have
even worse pandemics uh
but the ability of our uh
understanding of nature to give us
control and the
the in principle the resources that are
available to us
and the rise of our understanding of
mind i would say both our own
and the minds we create all all those
things
point to fantastic possibilities for a
bright future
yeah no i'm i'm deeply optimistic too
i would say though and i wonder if you
feel the same or not
i i like many i guess
never thought that our democracy was as
fragile
as it is i mean somehow you know in
school you're brought up to learn about
the three branches and the checks and
the balances but in the end
it ultimately comes down to the
integrity of the individual at some
level at some deep level
yes there are complex systems have
unexpected instabilities i guess
is the general lesson that people learn
in dealing with plasmas
and uh you can see it happening in
history and
systems failing in unexpected ways yeah
we can try to learn from it
and i think we hope i hope we can learn
from this experience but there are
some people of bad bad character and bad
will
unfortunately that yeah have gotten
gotten influential and somehow we have
to
work past that yeah you've certainly
done you know
a great job a heroic job obviously we'll
talk about your science in just a moment
but you spent a lot of effort
on reaching out to more general
members of the public you've written a
number of
books and we're going to talk about this
book here today
you know which is uh which is a
beautiful contribution you've also
written columns that i've enjoyed
looking at over the years and many
people have
and so do you feel that books
that like you write i mean i write books
too do they
preach to the converted or or do you
think that there's a real chance to uh
reach out beyond i think there's a
chance to reach out beyond
uh it's not it's a challenge
uh and frankly i think my previous books
have sort of been getting uh
more and more sophisticated in the way
they reach out as
and and presenting the science in ways
that are
more digestible uh i've gotten a lot of
feedback from friends
i've gotten questions and uh
found out what people have trouble with
also what people are really
interested in which is not necessarily
the specific facts it's
you know they they're not interested in
physics 101 or
they could they've taken courses and
they
they've managed to forget it and or
sometimes with
uh with prejudice so to speak but
what they're interested in is
understanding the world and enriching
their experience of the world
and they're very curious about what
we've achieved and what we know
not so much for the detailed facts or
the equations
but for the view of the world that it
leads and
why we believe in it and how it empowers
us yeah well well absolutely you know
and one of the wonderful things about
about your new book is if i can just
sort of show
it's not a thick book no it's not fake
to go through i have to tell you every
time i write a book i say to myself
this one's going to be a thin book yes
and this
this is for me a new departure too and
it was necessary to censor myself
and a couple of times i started all over
again
i had a very good editor christopher
richards who
kept me in line so to speak and uh and
and i kept i really this time i kept
thinking of specific
individuals i was writing for which were
the friends i mentioned whose questions
sort of stimulated
this uh effort and then also uh
um as as i was writing this book my
grandson was born and that made me think
but what would what what what could i
write for him that he would really
benefit from as he was growing up and
that made me think about myself as a
as a teenager when i was thinking about
what i wanted to do and what
what kind of questions i was asking so
that so
uh you know i wouldn't have wanted to
read or
i wouldn't have benefited very uh i mean
i might put it differently
there are plenty of places especially
nowadays and wikipedia
and and and and the web and
of course books where you can get
technical information
if you want it yeah but what people need
is an orientation
or i think what people can benefit from
is an orientation
clarity about the absolutely basic
fundamentals
and and it's a wonderful story
that we can i think we should be able to
present and expand people's minds with
yeah absolutely so i'm gonna we'll get
into that in just a moment but you you
mentioned
you know thinking of yourself as a as a
teenager and
yes we can we go back there just just
for a moment it's always nice for the
audience here to get uh
some something for me too
you grew up in new york right am i yes
yeah in uh
in queens way in the northeast corner of
uh yes northeast corner of queens almost
i could walk uh two or three minutes and
i would have been in nassau county so
wayne in the corner over there right so
i guess that may explain
because one of my questions was you know
many
i grew up in new york and and many
people who grew up and
went to school there went to bronx
science went to
high school but you you went more local
presumably it was just too far
it was basically too far it would it
would have been more than an hour
commute each way to bronze high school
of science for instance
right so that i talked about that with
my parents but it really wasn't a
sensible
thing to do clearly uh and uh
and the other side of the coin is that
uh the school
that i actually went to martin van buren
high school
uh at that time was quite a good school
and
uh and also was a very large school so
there were
classes at all different levels and it
suited me very well
yeah presumably you you you stood out
there
i would do this i mean you would have
stood out anywhere but uh
you know were you an anomaly did the
teachers not know what to do
with this kid who kind of presumably
well a little bit but
but you know that they threw me ahead a
couple of grades
so uh so at that point it uh
it was i i i i had
there was a cohort of us who who were
who could
meaningfully communicate and change and
trade ideas and
they were definitely subjects in which i
wasn't the best student
i imagined so like what like what
uh languages i'm not particularly good
at languages i terrible
truly terrible or awful at uh
at a drawing for some reason
yeah i want to come back to that someday
and learn to do it properly but it's not
natural
right no i i you know the pandemic is of
course this is time as many people start
to think well this is the time i'm going
to take up
drawing and during this uh yeah i think
i'm picking up juggling
i did and yeah and i have gone back and
i have gone back to languages i've
always been ashamed that i
don't know a foreign language so since i
now spend time in sweden i've decided to
learn swedish and i've made some
progress there
yeah i used to spend tweeting i didn't i
didn't pick up
pick up the language at all so but with
the juggling uh how's that going
it's uh well i i found a marvelous video
by uh someone named taylor glenn
which is an introduction to juggling and
i thought the beginning of that
it's very charming uh that but the
beginning was truly profound
she said that people think that juggling
is a process of throwing things and
catching things
but actually juggling is a process of
dropping things
so yes you have to when you see someone
doing it fluently
uh you're seeing the tip of a very large
iceberg of practice
it kind of reminds me of uh of calutsa
do you know kalutsa
learned to swim just by reading a book
on swimming and then
drove in you know so uh well i did that
too as an adult
i actually you know growing up in queens
i had very few opportunities to
meet the water and really got kind of a
phobia about
swimming but then as an adult when we
uh we bought a place by the lake in new
hampshire as a summer
place it seemed a pity not to be able to
swim in the lakes
so i read about it and took it up and
and and learned that
i guess i was 30 at the time that is a
true
theoretical physicist right
you can do anything by just figuring it
out and then just doing it
well there was definitely an
element of experimental trial and error
in it
but i love the love the expression that
i got from a uh
fortune cookie that i kind of made one
of my mottos which is
the work will teach you how to do it
the work will yeah yeah right through
practice you get it
yeah right yeah we we do so many things
subconsciously i mean consciousness is
is just a gloss on what's going on in
our brain really
and we do many many things that we don't
know how we do them starting with
well organizing our visual perception
talking
understanding standing up straight
walking
all these things we don't know how we do
them and that's been proved
by the halting progress of artificial
intelligence on all those fronts
that's right you know we don't know how
you know we have an amazing
storehouse of information that's
buried in there somehow and it comes
from interacting with the world
exactly that's
it's a in a really profound way we are
not
just individuals we're also we have
agglomerated a lot of the world into
into ourselves we're the beneficiary of
a hundred thousand generations of
forebears who built
up right and a lot of and also a lot of
feedback as we grow up
yeah absolutely i've watched you watch
babies doing experiments they drop
things and pick them up
or have someone else pick them up over
and over yeah you know i
you know when i when my kids were young
i i wanted
to see i like i wanted to see that
motion that moment
where language took hold and and yes i
remember the first words but somehow it
just
happens
yeah and it well it doesn't it's not it
doesn't happen in a micro second but it
but it happens uh in steps that are
and usually surprisingly fast yeah
yeah no and my daughter i mean her first
words were in response to
my son a little bit older and her first
words alec hit me
[Laughter]
you know so it was a it was it was out
of need you know to communicate
that's really the work teaching you how
to do it yeah totally
um so you you graduated high school
young
if i right like
15 when i well i was just around my 15th
my 16th birthday and you went from there
to university of chicago yes
right right so i want to ask you a
question about that you know i had a
graduate student who was 15.
you know cal take a 12. right and and it
was really tough
for him because yeah he had the
intellectual firepower but he didn't
have the emotional maturity
right to do that did you i mean what's
your view of rushing ahead so so quickly
as you did
well i didn't do it as fast as he did
i think i was basically pushing the
envelope of
what i would be comfortable recommending
because i did have i've had plenty of
friends and
uh maybe not quite a normal social life
i was
clearly less mature than my many of my
classmates and
along various axes uh but close enough
that i did get socialized and learned
how to deal with people
in in reasonable ways and of course i
picked up more at college
uh but i never felt disconnected
from my peers right right i mean i think
that's
if you can feel part of the social
environment then it can as you say
through the work
you can you know an accelerated rate and
from there you went
i should say also my parents and
particularly my mother was
you know kind of a very social person
and also kind of a saint in terms of
how supportive she was and how caring
she was she pushed did she push you or
was she hands off
my father pushed my mother my mother
just uh
support well she pushed in in a very
gentle way
she she didn't push but if
in some way i was failing or doing the
wrong thing she would just
be less happy than usual and i i was
very sensitive to that because
yeah i was okay so yeah i mean the whole
question of how hard to push your kids
is such a subtle one
you know and so depending on who the kid
is
you know their dna and yes right their
experiences
so and that that that worked very well
with my mother's technique
i i don't think it was something she was
calculating about was that
she was just so supportive in general
that and when something was wrong in her
mind
she just became a little less supportive
and
and i felt that very acutely yeah yeah
well look i mean there is nothing like a
mother man
i'm like a mother um so you went
from chicago to princeton did you go
directly to
uh and and david
uh was here david gross was your advisor
uh
well it's a little richer story than
that so i i
graduated in three years from chicago so
i was even you know more
more advanced yeah and more out of shape
out of
and uh i was i was i went to graduate
school in mathematics at princeton
because i still didn't really know what
i wanted to do
i wanted to keep my my options open
i was pretty sure i didn't want to do
pure mathematics actually so i got there
under somewhat false pretenses
and uh i had
up to then i had been
learning what other people did and i
had become pretty good at that you know
internal and uh
uh but it's a big i found it a big step
to go from
learning what other people did to doing
something different it's an
it's a big intimidating step also the
pace is much slower
you have to understand that not
everything you try is going to work and
so my first two years at princeton is
combination of
that kind of change and also not knowing
exactly what i wanted to do
it was kind of a crisis i was a lost
soul
and but but and i tried different things
i went to colloquia and all in biology
chemistry and different as well as
there was nascent computer science
growing up there but uh but i
lucked into uh i was very fortunate
because the math building and and
physics
are connected at princeton it was it was
and the math building is actually a big
tower so
it's kind of like i wander around so i
wandered into the physics
room place often and
i got the sense that very exciting
things were happening in physics that
used some of the kinds of mathematics
that i really liked
used analysis and group theory and
symmetry
and i came upon this very charismatic
young professor david gross who was
teaching quantum field theory and we
just hit it off
very very rapidly and you know within a
few months
after our first encounter we wrote those
papers
did you have physics back in other words
were you a math major at chicago
yeah i was a math major at chicago so i
did not have a convention i did not have
a conventional physics
education at all i picked up some i
picked up
you know i was interested in physics and
took quite a few courses
but it wasn't my major uh i had read
the feynman lectures as they came out
originally
and and i thought i understood them but
you know
in retrospect i clearly did not
understand them in
in in a in a a an operational profound
way
uh but so i was vaguely aware of of
physics but i did not have a proper
education here i mean i mean did you
take a course in quantum field theory
well that's how i met david i took i
said in on his class in quantum field
theory
okay i thought i should learn because i
i there were lectures by
ken wilson and about renormalization
group
he was visiting princeton and uh uh
i knew sydney coleman was going to be
around
anyway there's a sense of excitement so
i i uh and i
was always interested in quantum field i
i
i had treasured as uh as before that
as a student uh books by hermann weil
uh and uh einstein was a great hero of
mine
even when i was a teenager a younger
teenager and uh
so i and and as i mentioned the feynman
books so
so i i and i and as an undergraduate i
also read dirac's
quantum mechanics book and i really
liked that because it was kind of a
different approach to linear algebra
right and very clean very clean very
thin
and was it less than 100 pages or
something i think it's the whole thing
right
uh well this it depends where you decide
to stop
but yeah the basic the basic framework
of quantum mechanics is spelled out
and very succinctly for sure yeah
and uh
you know if you want to look at his
views on quantum electrodynamics and so
forth and then then it's it's
it's more but uh the uh
uh so all so i was interested in physics
but i as i
i didn't have a proper education anyway
i was so i went i decided
this this quantum field theory course
was was being offered and that was a
nice
clean subject that uh you didn't have to
have a lot of background for
so i did that and david was the teacher
so there was the professor and that was
really inspiring
and and so i i did did
i guess in your interaction with him did
this
idea naturally bubble up to calculate
as we call the beta function well it
wasn't the first idea we discussed we
discussed many ideas
yeah uh for possible things i remember
at one point i was proposing to
calculate neutrino neutrino scattering
because this is this
this is the kind of thing that i was
thinking but
but uh i wanted to i i i
understood that the the theory of the
weak interactions was kind of breaking
open that the gates theories were really
promising
in different ways and uh the the model
wasn't clear
that what the correct model was or what
whether the possibilities along these
lines had been exhausted
so i wanted to do that and then uh
david was very interested in
renormalization group as you
and and and wilson of course had given
these lectures about renormalization
groups
so then uh in our conversations
eventually we wandered over to the
question of
calculating the how
the short distance properties of the the
renormalization group would apply to the
gauge theories and uh that's that's
that's and they were interesting formal
questions because
scaling is not manifestly gauging
variant
and that i thought that was a nice clean
problem and then it was just calculating
david had a much longer standing
of uh trying to show that quantum field
theory could not describe the strong
interaction
is trying to show that no way no how
uh but uh but when we calculated in the
non-abelian theories we found that there
was a way and not only
was there a way but was sufficiently
unique as a guiding principle that it
led
to are you like a unique candidate
theory for the strong interaction which
is called qcd and we've got we we got it
and we were able to figure out ways of
testing it
and you know we it was way ahead of the
experiments at the time but
eventually they caught up yeah so we
showed actually before you came on we
showed
your paper with dave we can probably
bring it up again
you know it's it's it's it's beautifully
succinct
short and and the key equation of course
um maybe not exactly in the form that
you wrote it down i think we can bring
up
uh that's a letter yeah the letter is
here right
that's right so can you bring can we
bring up the the
the the beta function equation i just
want to ask frank one one question
about that so so here's one version of
that
and and the insight that the
interaction between the quarks you know
gets weaker and weaker
as you get closer together it's all in
that minus sign in there
that's right well
well that minus sign when we calculated
it
it was just it was literally that we did
a calculation
uh it was at the time it was a
technically challenging calculation
and uh sort of broke new ground and
technique
but it was not how should i say it was
not a very conceptual calculation
we followed the rules that feynman and
fideo and popoff and some pioneers had
had laid down for how to do gage
theories
and uh
and the you know this this this answer
emerged
and you know to our credit we knew what
to do with it
but uh the conceptual like understanding
emerged in the over the next two or
three years of why
this happens and kind of more
picturesque terms
but at at first it was just a
calculation that gave a minus sign
did it if it was very important it was
going to not be a minus sign
i was at least not just ignorant enough
not to
not have a prejudice
but did that make you nervous that so
much hinged
i mean minus signs are things that we
often get right
you know yeah i don't think i've
uh oh well no i wasn't i mean we
there were many ways of checking the
calculation i calculated
all kinds of gauges i compared known
results in qed and so there were many
men
there was no question about the song
once everything settled down
the the hard part of the calculation
sort of
at the level of uh
nitty gritty was just making all these
cross checks
agree with each other and once they did
the overall answer was clear
so i wasn't worried about that but what
i was worried about was
you know is is this a meaningful result
and despite the questions about gauge
and variance
is uh and of course does it apply to the
world
when we when we wanted to have it the
strong in a way that didn't bother me so
much
at that point i was interested in
getting a thesis
and doing something that would kind of
establish
me as a as a uh
as a person that would would have a job
and the the uh
but uh so i was i i wasn't worried
about the the question of whether so
much
i mean it would of course i would be
great if it would if
it described the world no question and i
was already
immediately thinking about getting a
nobel prize for it because
if it was correct it was the theory of
the strong interaction yeah but
i i was less worried about the upside
i was less worried about
i was less worried about that was that
was sort of gravy okay
that was fun fun to fantasize about but
clearly
there were there were uh issue nature
would have something to say about it and
experimental physics would have
something to say about it it wasn't
clear at all at first
that testing the theory would be easy
we had logarithmic corrections to this
or that which were
you know notoriously difficult to sort
out
the experiments that we sort of used as
our lever were very
very crude uh we were you know
just the phenomena of scaling which was
the thing we were trying to explain
was kind of yeah pretty
semi-quantitative but we wanted to say
that
oh yes so this it's actually
scaling but also slight deviations from
scaling and this was way beyond
way beyond the evidence at the time
and what was the reaction i mean with
this uh result yeah reaction was mixed
i would say uh there were a few people
who
immediately took it up and became very
enthusiastic
uh
the people at harvard who were doing
gage theories for other reasons
i saw so ways of uh they were
that was very welcome to them to to have
a theory of the strong interaction that
that could could be used ken wilson
i think was a very enthusiastic from the
very beginning
he had ideas about confinement which we
really didn't we only had
we only saw that the problem was
difficult we didn't really have a
concrete picture of how confinement
would emerge
uh that
but but uh people i thought of as
as sort of older and wiser like td lee
for instance said well you know people
see approximate scaling in different
circumstances in nuclear physics they
could me
it could mean this it could mean that
and they're also more or less plausible
alternative explanations of the things
that we were explaining
uh so it was mixed uh and but the most
common
reaction was no reaction at all because
people didn't understand what we were
doing
right right you knew at the time yeah
for sure
and and so you know it's a funny thing
in physics
when results are sufficiently novel they
can generate the response that you're
noting but over time they become
the ones that are right become absorbed
in such a deep way that it's almost like
[ __ ] nature
it becomes it's like oh yeah well i
actually talk about this in the book
i uh
as as a young faculty member val fitch
was the chairman at princeton
and well for and he was he became quite
a good friend
uh and he was of course the
experimentalist who
discovered uh time reversal symmetry
violation
yep or cp violation but it's really
related uh and i was talking with him
and i was telling him my bright ideas
about matter antimatter asymmetry
and how that might be developed
cosmologically
and i think even about axions at that
time
which was inspired by this t-violation
phenomena
and i was talking about t violation like
it was history
you know not not not as not real
not thinking that he he was uh he was
the guy who discovered he remembered
very well when it wasn't a part of
reality and the startling new revelation
and he said
uh he he looked kind of wistful i don't
think he was hurt he was amused he was
very
very nice sweet fellow and very uh
serene he said uh well i guess
yesterday's sensation is today's
calibration
right i've seen that i've seen that with
qcd originally
when we you know for many years maybe
for 10 or 15 years
after our breakthroughs uh
when they were you know after a couple
of years it
became credible that this was maybe the
theory of the strong interaction
uh got a lot of theoretical support
but uh at international conferences
there would also
always be major
plenary talks about status of qcd
the status of the strong interaction uh
where people would talk about the
evidence was it convincing was it
and it was slowly building and getting
better and better uh and that was
that was a that was one of the big
highlights maybe the highlight of
this kind of international conference
for for quite a few years
uh but now uh the same activity in fact
much more sophisticated the same kind of
activity measurements and uh
calculations of strong interaction
processes at
high energies uh have become a very
highly developed art and now it's called
calculating backgrounds because people
want to want to take take it for granted
and the
the whole idea that this theory might be
falsified in a big way is no longer
really
credible so the focus of interest is
using it
as a way of uh uh establishing a
baseline for looking for deviations and
those those would be the interesting
things right yeah right
yeah it is funny how that works i had a
similar
experience when i was a graduate student
i learned about the higgs mechanism
and it was taught in such a way that i
had no idea
things had never been found
wrong perspective that you know this was
a done deal because everyone was
treating
it as if it was a done deal and then of
course it just becomes as you say
ultimately uh the background within a
more novel phenomenon you try to you
mentioned axions
in what we were just discussing i wonder
if we could turn to that for
a moment that's another i mean you you
named axion you discovered this
idea yeah um i i saw in your book you
even give uh
genesis of the name which was uh
you may want to mention i had no idea
that it's a laundry detergent
right that i uh once when i was shopping
with my mother i think
i think it was probably must have been
when i was in college and home
home for a holiday or the summer uh
went shopping and saw this detergent
on on the shelf called axion
and i said to myself gosh that really
sounds like it ought to be a particle
that
you know it it fits with pion or
meson or baryon or ion or anion
cation and you know all these so uh
so it really and it's also you know it's
a greek root clearly
and it's nice and short so really catchy
so uh
so i said to you know i said i really
did say to myself
i say a lot of nonsense to myself but i
remember this that that if i had a
chance to
name a particle i would try to name an
accident see if i could there's a way i
could bring in axion
and uh and years later uh
not actually not that many years later a
little bit later uh the
the uh the opportunity arose because
there was this remarkable
sort of qualitatively new kind of
particle
that clearly deserved its name and its
motivation its deserved a name and its
motivation
was a problem that has to do with the
axial baryon number current
it's a little bit of a stretch but close
enough
and that that was close enough to sell
to a physical review letters which is
very conservative about this if i
you know if i told them i was naming it
after a laundry detergent there's no way
that the name would have been accepted
but
i didn't tell anybody until afterwards
try to submit a paper to physical review
with the name of a particle called a
spermion
spermion right that's what we now call
tadpoles yeah
right and that did that they rejected it
did not fly they
they rejected that right and i think
also this was
way before my time but but uh i think
murray gelman originally talked about
curious particles not strange particles
but that was not allowed right right
yeah good thank goodness yeah right
yeah we have enough uh already
but the action now is um still
hypothetical
article that has not been detected but
you have put forward
the case and many people thousands of
people have written papers on the
possibility that this puzzle of the dark
matter yeah might be resolved
with the axion now there was a time when
it was a footnote
in thinking about dark matter i mean it
was kind of there i mean hopefully i i
don't mean
not anything like me but yeah you're
right you're absolutely right
footnote is being kind it was kind of
regarded as a nut cult
of
but things have changed now right i mean
change no now it's
uh well at least it's uh if it's in that
cult it's kind of
it's kind of grown into an uh
a respectable religion or
it has lots of adherence and is
uh supported by uh you know supported by
funding agencies and
and serious experimental efforts all
around the world
to to detect the thing so it has a very
well developed theory
it was and to me one of the most
impressive things
about it is that
it was introduced to solve a theoretical
problem in fundamental physics
having to do with the fact this time
reversal property that the
laws of physics look very very nearly
the same
if you run them backwards in time uh the
fundamental laws that is
that uh
but when we worked out
what the consequences of this new
particle
would be when you ran it through big
bang cosmology
we found that it gets produced in great
abundance and has just the right
properties
to make the dark matter and that case
has become stronger and stronger over
time
both in the fact in the way that uh
um the theoretical concepts around the
axion have
been battle tested for for 40 plus years
and and
survived every challenge uh with flying
colors
uh it even emerges from string theory
for instance there's their ax
the uh um then
uh the
uh experimental limits on the axiom the
axion
has the theory has an undetermined
parameter so axions could
could have different properties
depending on one parameter
it's very much like the higgs particle
which we didn't know the mass but once
you knew the mass you knew everything
else
and the range of axion masses
that where it would not be dark matter
have pretty much been excluded so if you
have axions at all so if you're going to
solve this problem at all
you need axions and then if you have
axions at all you're going to get dark
matter
and and that's so that's one thing
that's happened one
big cluster of things that happen has
happened the other big cluster of thing
that has happened is uh that kind of
the competition has uh has not
fared well yeah that people originally
thought maybe neutrinos
some kind of neutrinos would be the dark
matter but that's
that's pretty well ruled out by now
there were ideas that
uh so-called wimps associated with super
symmetry
uh would be uh the dark matter and that
uh you know that that's been the subject
of very heavy
experimental observe uh efforts
but so far both low energy super
symmetry
and directly searching for the wimps
have come up empty
let me ask you a question about that
though because it's do you find it
is it just curious just a coincidence i
could and people have
say many of the same words about super
symmetry and super symmetric dark matter
i mean
in super symmetry you're trying to solve
a completely separate problem
not the dark matter problem solve the
hierarchy problem
and then within supersymmetry these wimp
particles
they naturally are produced in the right
abundance to be the dark
matter you don't have to fight more or
less
more or less yeah i wouldn't open it
order magnitude or so
yeah so is it is it
why i i i i
have been an advocate for low energy
certification as you know it's also
the the the way the couplings unify is
improved
yeah you have low energy super symmetry
that to me is really
powerful quantitative evidence in that
direction
uh but
uh low energy supersymmetry is not
really a theory in quite the same way as
the
axion theory is it has many more than
one parameter
yeah and there are certainly regions of
parameter space
where you can retain the good features
and yet the contribution
to dark matter would be subdominant or
super
really subdominant not uh so
so it's a little bit so it's it has i
you know i still i wouldn't be shocked
or appalled if some version of
super symmetry and wimps turns out to be
an important part of the picture
uh it really should be
but uh right but but
uh i at this point i'd be disappointed
if axions weren't the dominant
uh contributor to the dark matter
any sense of time frame when there'll be
some experiments well
[Music]
i i've been saying five or ten years for
quite a long time but i i do think we're
getting more realistic
about uh and and and
as you as you alluded to the world is
getting more serious about it many many
more
experimental efforts are being mounted i
think
really for the first time recently one
one experiment the admx experiment has
actually
developed sufficient sensitivity that
they would have detected the
cosmological
background of axions if they had masses
within a certain narrow range
so it's only now that we are developing
the technology that clearly
is going to put the theory to the test
yeah and
you know it's difficult to say how long
it's going to take i would be
well
it could happen any day but that would
require
a lot of luck at least
no existing experiment except for admx
can do
anything and and and they only their
their progress is
uh slow and uh
they have to look at one mass at a time
and it's a slow process
uh so
but i i'm working on some antenna
designs with collaborators that i really
think will might improve things and
are there lots of ideas so uh
it's i can't say for sure but i i
wouldn't be
i wouldn't bet against the possibility
of uh discovery on a time scale of say
five or ten years right all right so are
you a tinkerer i mean do you build stuff
when you
talk about you do yeah well i don't
build serious how should i say
i don't build serious stuff but i build
uh models i like to build models i like
i like toys i always have like toys
games of all kinds yeah so i do
so um what do you think about these
ideas
that people put forward that maybe the
whole dark matter paradigm
might be wrong and we just need to
really rethink
our understanding of gravity itself uh
not much i mean you know it's one of
these situations where
it walks like a duck and waddles like a
duck and quacks like a duck it's
probably a dog
yeah the dark the dark mat there are
many many ways of accessing this
phenomenon
and they all
fit quite snugly into the so-called
dark matter paradigm so you know it's on
the scale of galaxies on clusters of
galaxies going back to the micro
background radiation perturbations
uh in the early universe it's all makes
it consistent the way
they cost the way they're distributed
around galaxies night and they're
clumped but not as clumped as the
regular matter
it all fits together and people who've
done numerical simulations like carlos
frank have done had spectacular success
uh based on starting with
uh standard big bang
parameters many of which are pinned down
experimentally and running it forward
and getting something that
is at least a good caricature of our
universe right so
people who have want to develop
alternatives have a lot to answer for
and the existing attempts are not
impressive at all
yeah right general relativity is hard to
change
yeah it is you can add to it but it's
hard to change
for sure it's a profound theory yeah and
the amazing thing is
you know even the parts of general
relativity that
you can say einstein himself was less
than convinced
about you know gravitational waves he
was sort of on the fence
right yeah oh my goals totally on the
fence it was paper i think in 1938 where
he tried to prove that black was
couldn't form that's right
exactly he thought he he really did he
was confused about
the the horizon being a singularity and
yep yep
yeah um so yeah he really put forward
something that
you know and of course he struggled with
the cosmological terms
as another big one he introduced it but
uh rejected it
ultimately on a combination of empirical
and aesthetic grounds
yeah i don't think he would have been
terribly upset well actually that's not
zero
you may be aware of this but you know
the famous story of course is the one
that gamma
tells where einstein says you know it
was the greatest blunder of my life
you know uh but there is a talk
of his that i saw a transcript where
einstein says
it will be in the future yeah
measurements will determine whether
there is a cosmological
concept he didn't just sort of wipe it
away the way the story seems to suggest
so i think he would be totally on board
yeah i'm sure of it yeah yeah without a
doubt
um so let's turn to um you know this
book
uh i never get my left to right correct
with these cameras there all right
there it is exactly yeah um this came
out i think just a couple days ago or
two days ago yeah two days ago
now three days ago the 12th
right so you know this is we began to
speak about it a little bit but i want
to go a little bit further
now i mean your your motivation here is
clearly
to give insight into a scientific
mindset
as opposed to the the detailed
forefront this newfangled discovery that
you know it's really about
how do you see the world through the
eyes of a scientist and the beauty of
that
and the way that that viewpoint
naturally
engages with the very human yes
so exactly
but i also i also in each chapter i let
myself speculate a little bit at the end
because again when i wrote this for my
friends as i say
i'm curious i have some very specific
people in mind i don't want to embarrass
them but
but but uh but
they they all asked
the same kind of questions about you
know what does it all mean
can what do you actually do and
what's coming next so uh so i
i talk about i try to
be clear about what we do understand and
that's a lot
uh but also convey the and and why we
believe what we believe
and uh i think we can i can speak for we
in this in this context
uh that we have a lot of overlap but
the uh um
and that's a process and it's historical
and i try to talk about
how it might have been different so
these things shouldn't seem too obvious
to you
and uh and put it in the context of
experiencing the world and anticipating
what might happen in the future but i
i'm very careful to speculate
to i'm sorry too uh to speculate i do
speculate but to separate the
speculations from
from the facts from the facts and and
things that and
when in the kind of facts to give at
least some indication of
why they're facts why we call them facts
right
yeah and so what is your i mean my
writing
process is i don't i don't have long
outlines i just sort of dive in but then
i'm
a revision i re revive right a similar
thing for you my wife tells me that all
good writing is rewriting and i do
rewrite a lot and it's particularly this
book
the reason it became short was that i
did a lot of surgery and amputation
of a much much more extended
detailed kind of wandering text in in
retrospect
uh and so it's all high points
and uh that but i do
i do out i do outline a lot and uh
and you can see that this book is very
structured it's in 10 parts and each
part has some parts
some of the scaffolding is still visible
more or less
look like the proposal yes
and broadly broadly
however i would say as it developed it
became
more uh
culturally and philosophically connected
yeah
and less less purely technical yeah
right you know you make a
i brought in a history of ideas
yeah some poetry some history in the in
the sense of history
especially but especially history of
ideas and science going
also going back to the ancient greeks
and and other
philosophical traditions to talk about
how people
it could have been different right these
guys weren't dopes
these guys and uh so tech coming putting
yourself
in the mindset of
powerful minds who thought differently
is really mind is really an expansion of
mine this and closely related to
uh a great theme to me of of
modern science which is complementarity
right there should be
there are valid different ways of
looking at things
that you should to to to do
justice to reality you should be ready
to take them all in
yeah we're totally on the same
perspective there my own recent book
i had a similar idea expressed
differently that
that they're just many levels at which
you can analyze
reality and the question is part of it
what level is the right one and that
level has its own language its own
vocabulary or its own yeah
that's right and and knowing knowing
what's going on two or three levels
below might not be
terribly relevant to uh right right if
you're
if you're in a jury on a legal case
it doesn't really help very much to know
that the the uh
the victim and the perpetrator are made
out of quarks and gluons
right i love you very much
funny thing though a jury i was in a
jury in a criminal case and
in the closing remarks that the defense
attorney
looks to me and says and you don't have
to be a quantum physicist
right and in the hallway i read your
books you know
yeah but uh and he was right the
defendant was uh
not guilty in terms of the evidence to
put forward but anyway um
but i want to ask you a question uh
about that so
so we're
totally uh on the same page regarding
that
perspective but there was a moment in in
reading your book where
i wasn't sure we were completely on the
same page and i wonder if you wouldn't
want to spend a moment talking about it
it wasn't the issue is the issue of free
will
i think we do agree but i think we
probably say it slightly differently so
so you come to the
argument that asking whether
we are free in the context of a
reductionist perspective it's kind of
the wrong
question to ask you know free will this
human conception it's up here at this
level the human level
yeah other level of reality down there
the quarks the gluons the
electrons and so forth and it's that
other
so when it comes to certain things that
bifurcation makes a lot of sense to me
we talk about
love and and guilty or not in a trial or
hate or grief or anxiety you know those
qualities
those sensations of human experience it
doesn't make a lot of sense to try to
talk about them in their in the
reductionist language they're just
you know different and free will is a
very very useful concept
very useful but here's what i would say
tell me if you agree with this
so so when we talk about the sensation
say of love or hate or grief
that human sensation i agree needs to be
thought of distinctly from the
reductionist account
if we talk about the sensation of free
will
then i would also agree needs to be
separated out
but i do find that there is value in
thinking about at least a certain kind
of freedom it may be a matter of
definition
you know when we think of free will as
having control over the physical
unfolding then we start to use a
language that's so
similar to the physical and funding down
the reductions account that i do find it
useful
to ask the question that you say that we
shouldn't ask now is it because your
definition of
is more the sensation the human
sensation of free will
is is that where we use slightly
different language
well i think there is a phenomenon of
free will i mean
here it is i can put raise my hand or
not and i'm gonna
decide do you tell me what to do and
i'll do the opposite right
and free will is an essential concept in
law
you know we give an insanity defense if
we say that someone is not in control of
their decisions
and yep and so forth uh
now so it's a very useful concept and
in many kinds and this is necessary to
address certain kinds of questions
uh the great
problem i think that a better way to
state
the problem that is usually discussed in
terms of free will versus determinism
to me a much better way a phrasing of
the problem is uh
does mind emerge from matter and how
yeah
that and i absolutely do believe
that mind emerges from matter right uh
and
i you know we've we've seen how uh
metabolism emerges from matter how
heredity emerges from matter at a
molecular level and you can even go down
further
if you wanted to uh we understand uh
we don't yet have that account for mind
uh clearly but but so far there are no
show stoppers the neurobiologists have
not come into
any phenomenon where they have had to
invoke souls or something other
than the same sort of thing that we
discuss in our core theories or standard
model
and it seems that it doesn't seem to be
anything missing
and even more than that you know we do
very very
we meaning the scientific community
uh do very very delicate sensitive
experiments where we have to
make sure we control all kinds of things
stray magnetic fields straight radio
waves people walking by tremors
of the earth and so forth but we've
never had to make corrections for what
the guy next door is thinking
right be careful not to think certain
thoughts or you'll mess up the
experiment
so uh so
so i think maybe that's what you're
getting at that that
definitely big part of it there's no uh
so i i'm very sympathetic to the idea
that
that we can get to a deep understanding
of mind and lay a foundation for
the phenomena we observe
in terms of molecules and ultimately
quarks and so
forth uh however
having done that i still think we'll
talk about free will
and that's and that's an example of the
nested layers
you know the different languages that
women use
it would be virtually impossible to
excise the
language and concepts surrounding free
will from everyday human discourse
but in my mind i always say okay but i
really mean it's the
sensation of that free will but because
mind emerges from men matter is fully
governed by these physical laws
my ability to intercede in those
physical laws is that's a loser
it's really not that straightforward i
don't think because the
the uh there are phenomena of
quantum uncertainty and chaos and
sheer numbers that make
the uh idealization
that we can just compute what's going to
happen and not to mention a human being
is or brain is not a closed system so
the whole universe gets involved
the uh and that's not just a that's not
the metaphor i mean you see things and
that changes what you think
the uh uh so
i think there are questions about
what the way you know in in quantum
mechanics the
if you know the wave function then the
evolution is deterministic but you don't
know the wave function even in principle
you don't know
so it's not clear i mean so i mean it is
what it is we'll discover as
as we work out what the dis what what
the
the facts are and presuming
it's true how mind emerges from matter
it'll be much clearer how to talk about
it yeah uh
but i don't think the kind of
laplacian crude determinism that
it's just a matter of solving the
equations and if we were we were
cleverer we would be able to do that uh
i
i think that that doesn't do justice to
the situation
the the the calculations are so
impractical
yeah and but even more it's not even
clear that they make sense in principle
because uh they're so uh it's just not
an appropriate way to describe this
yeah i mean i would agree at the level
of predictive capacity
i totally agree with the perspective
that you lay out
for me though it's a question of what
are the governing principles and is
there the ability of the human mind to
intercede
in the physical unfolding in a manner
that somehow is distinct from
yeah or theory we touched on exactly
those two points and i i think we do
agree on those i don't
i don't think there's any evidence yeah
it's certainly worth investigating and
my god it would be the greatest
discovery of all it would be
uh greatest discovery of all time in my
opinion if you could show that there's
influence of my matter that's separate
from
uh influence of matter on matter exactly
uh
and we have very sensitive instruments
now
yeah that then
uh and and
that uh we will understand how
mind emerges from matter in the same
at the same level as we understand how
metabolism
emerges from matter how heredity emerges
from matter
or for that matter we've we're
constructing minds
we're constructing uh new kinds of minds
that are getting very powerful
and getting you know up to human and in
some cases superhuman levels on some
fronts
and uh yeah so that'll that'll give us
examples of minds that emerge from
matter
exactly we'll also i think in you know
over the course of
the next few centuries maybe the next
that will make progress
on the next few decades but certainly in
the next few centuries we'll
have a very rich understanding of how
human minds emerge from matter
and uh well if
it works out the way i think it'll work
out that you know minds do emerge
matter and and there are no such effects
then then i think we agree on
those those it's kind of the observable
correlates of this discussion now
what do you want to say that's the
absence of free will i'm not sure i'm
willing to go with you there because
free will is a very useful concept and i
experience it
so there's something that we have to do
justice to
as part of understanding how mind
emerges from matter
yeah i mean there's two points that i
would make on that so yeah i think we
we do pretty much fully agree but the
one point is make is
i think there is an implication of these
ideas for
some of the concepts that you mentioned
for even for the judicial
system right because when i think
in the manner of the absence of
traditional free will not sort of the
everyday useful concept of it
it eliminates the knee-jerk reaction for
retribution
in certain circumstances it adds a
certain kind of empathy
to circumstances so so punishment now
becomes more just a teaching tool
behavior stimulus of punishment as
opposed to
punishing for the sake of revenge and i
think that
change of attitude at least it helped me
get to that change of attitude through
thinking
in this way well that's i think
well i think that's wonderful even if
it's not quite right i think it's a
wonderful byproduct and uh i think i
would i would reach similar conclusions
by
related but but just a little bit
different routes yeah that
but i do agree that you know think
internalizing this concept of
complementarity
that different descriptions are uh
appropriate
and by internalizing i think one of the
great lessons of our fundamental
understanding
is that the distinction between self and
not self
is somewhat superficial and that we're
all in this universe together we're made
out of the same sort of stuff
and expanding your circle of empathy
very very
wide and you know sort of internalizing
the idea that
there's also other forms of wisdom that
say uh
put yourself in the other guy's shoes or
we're all god's children
i i think that that those lessons are
not contradicted by fundamental
understanding in the way you come to
them
uh by different paths yeah totally agree
now you mentioned the possibility of
creating mind in a
in a machine in a computer and yeah it
doesn't
i agree i don't think there's any
fundamental obstacle
to that i don't know how long it will
take and we begin to see already
with systems like you know alphago and
yeah
gene folding or a deep mind you know
these systems that they can learn on
their own they just study the data they
study the patterns
yeah yeah so so it does suggest you
mention this in your book
it does suggest that at some point we
may have these devices that can
you know in an hour or 15 minutes
rederive
all of of human understanding you know
and and so what what do you think about
that is that the future
that we're headed toward and does it
have an impact on
when you think about the work you're
doing you know it changes our
understanding
it changes the world but when you say oh
and a machine will be able to do that in
30 seconds you know in the 25th century
you know does that does that color
anything that you do it is a lesson in
humility isn't it
i i do i well let me
let me get a prop here
[Music]
we're waiting for frank to come back for
a show-and-tell anybody just joined us
this is uh this is archaeopteryx
[Music]
i keep arcticus on my desk as a constant
reminder of this
that uh i read a book by
uh olaf stapleton one of the visionary
geniuses of science
uh well i've read several of his books
made a big impression on me but one
i think maybe the first one that i read
was called odd john
it's about a superhuman intelligence in
this case it was a mutant but
a similar idea that was just
able to function at a different level
and the the biography of john is written
by a normal human
and at one stage uh
i john is talking to this uh the
biographer and says
you are the optic archaeopteryx of the
spirit
and i think
we have to realize that we we
we can do we can we are able to
comprehend the world remarkably well
astonishingly well uh
but we can certainly
gra see that there there are
uh more powerful ways of
more uh powerful internet in information
processing
uh uh and uh
uh absorbing and abstract
whatever more powerful thinkers on the
horizon more powerful
mines on the horizon and uh
that's okay i mean we it doesn't
uh you know we humans are already
not the best at not we still have
uh uh athletic competitions even though
cars can move much faster and so for we
still love birds even though airplanes
can
move faster and higher and so forth and
carry things uh
and even at a more practical level today
i wouldn't be able to work at the same
level without my silicon
friend here that that helps me do
calculations and
and picture things and and just gather
information uh
that's stored on the internet and so uh
so
i think we'll have a co-evolution uh the
human mind will have a co-evolution and
the
maybe the vanguard of thought will no
longer be things
uh encased in human skulls
but that's okay they'll be better
they'll be better than us
if if we do it right you know of course
there are many ways things could go
wrong but i
i hope that there'll be a co-evolution a
period of transition and and
and uh humans will continue to
to live and thrive and and be enriched
by
by this but they won't be the vanguard
of mind anymore
and of course it could be that we do
evolve to a form where the flesh and
blood version
of ourselves is something part of the
distant past right it could be
that well yeah that right we could i
mean
my actually ray kurzweil who's here
yeah one of the visionaries of this kind
of thing
was came from that same high school as
me oh is that true
yeah just a couple of years before i
think well i did i didn't know him and i
still don't know him very well but uh
but yeah he there's something in the air
2020 if i remember to be the singularity
yeah i don't i don't believe in the
singularity i think not
i think you know in the and in the
parlance of physics it's going to be a
crossover it'll be a gradual
sure which is fortunate because it's
going to be very complicated to adjust
to and i think
it's another case where the work will
teach us how to do it we'll interact
with these things and
and have a chance to give them feedback
on uh
on how they're doing and
and and uh to build up
relationships and and you know maybe
i think an important part of the future
will be cyborgs so human human
brains and even closer partnership with
our computers than now
uh and yeah so it i don't think anyone
is smart enough to predict how this is
going to work out in detail
yeah uh but experience will will
i i do have a lot well not faith but a
hope
hope that uh and and and
expectation i guess guarded expectation
that uh increased intelligence will also
be associated with
increased empathy and increased
experience of the world
yep so it'll all be good it's not and we
shouldn't be jealous
that that that you know
our ancestors will be longer lived
and wiser and kinder than we are we
should right
i mean so a lot of this conversation is
predicated not completely but partly
under the assumption that the so-called
hard
problem of consciousness is one that
isn't actually a problem right this
an inner world can emerge so do you see
an inner world
merely as the byproduct of
certain complex processes is that enough
of an answer to you or do you
does it puzzle you at all it certainly
needs to be worked out in much more
detail
and i'm sure the details might turn out
to be very surprising
but i think you know with if your
standards of explanation are low enough
i think you can already see
the outlines of how it might work and
some experimental support for the ideas
that
most of what's going on in our brains is
subconscious we already
mentioned how we don't really know how
we walk or how we set
but we certainly don't even people have
tried to study it very carefully
haven't gotten very far and uh and
visual processing you know we know a lot
of bits and pieces but it's like the
theory of the strong interaction before
qcd
it's not really a functional theory
uh the uh
but uh where was i going with this i'm
sorry
you know whether we can come up with
that right but but i think there is uh
there is there are experimental
indications that that most of what we do
is subconscious
however that there is a kind of
necessity to organize it all there's an
executive function that needs to be
uh needs to be in place for very
plausible
evolutionary reasons just to make sense
of it all right and
make sure all these units are working
together and
that if you think about it that would
have to be something like consciousness
that says
it's a and and there are famous
experiments which i
uh mentioned in the book actually where
you can see that there's a separate
process of
a unit making decisions and then
reporting it to consciousness right and
that's a separate process
separated in time and place from where
where it's actually done and where it's
reported so when you think you're
willing something you're actually
uh just uh
accepting the report of what your
unconscious actually did
now there are a lot of uh you know the
global workspace theory michael graziano
the attention scheme of theory i think
these are
and they're but they're ideas they're
not just theories they're there were
experiments by
benjamin leiber especially with the
pioneer but they're not by now there are
hundreds of experiments
yeah along these lines of separating
the decision-making process from
conscious
experience they are not the same thing
and
so a couple more things if you have a
couple minutes i just wanted to
get your your feeling on you know
physics science more generally
makes progress usually because there's
some kind of
tension some kind of the parts don't fit
together
and and we have a bunch of those on the
table at the moment and i'm wondering
what your thoughts are and one is and
you and i once spoke about this a long
time ago and
you didn't seem very interested to talk
about it so you may dismiss me again
right here but
the quantum measurement problem um
you know that you know we have
schrodinger's equation it allows us to
calculate how the wave function the
probability wave evolves in time yeah to
go from that to the definite world
of actual outcomes is still
problematic as far as the detailed
mathematical description goes
i think of that as part but not
necessarily the most salient part of
this
question of seeing myself in the
equations
you know to see how within the equations
of quantum mechanics
you can construct sort of step by step
well not just quantum mechanics but but
the world as we actually know so qcd and
quantum load
uh at least in broad you you of course
you'll have to
make simplified models along the way and
idealizations but
just the broad in broad strokes
how you can construct something that we
would recognize
as uh our experience of the world
yeah saying so not we wouldn't be
talking about
doing experiments we'd be talking about
you know doing experiencing the world
and and then to show that uh
this description
[Music]
has the properties that that we actually
experience
that's somewhat of a scandal is that to
me is that
we uh we have this marvelous very
successful description
of the micro world and there's no reason
to think that we can't
step by step ascend a different levels
of description and reach
[Music]
the macro world and we do that very
effectively at the level of designing
engineering structures and semi
computers and so forth
but to get all the way from there to see
how mind emerges from matter and then to
see how
the world as we experience it emerges
from that description of mind
that loop has definitely not been closed
yeah but i
i'm not sure that separately thinking
about the so-called measurement problem
is going to help very much
right i mean does that suggest that you
are more in a many worlds like camp that
it will just be schrodinger's equation
and nothing else will be needed
once this other level of analysis can be
undertaken
yeah i hope so i hope so uh
although there just seemed to be a big
gap somewhere
in in the axiomatic structure of quantum
mechanics at least as far as i've been
able to see
uh somewhere you have to introduce uh
concepts of probability and yeah
and and interpretation i really like i
was
i have been very influenced by a book
called the consistent quantum theory by
robert griffiths
yeah i know the book yeah that that uh
i mean not only is it very clarifying
but i think it's actually useful in in
making little models of quantum
mechanical phenomena i've been using it
in my work and there'll be some papers
soon
that this the uh um
but so he so those models are sufficient
the models that are
described in that book he are fully
consistent with the principles of
quantum mechanics and sort of
recognizable
descriptions of actual experimental
situations
and i think really as stripped down as
they could possibly be
given those constraints and
you can't get away from this damn
assumption of a probability
interpretation i don't see how so i
think that might have to be added to the
schrodinger equation
right right um so going from the small
to the big
you know there is some some people claim
there's tension not everyone does
between you know the inflationary
cosmological
perspective and some of the other ideas
that even
you know paul steinhardt one of the
architects
of the inflationary paradigm has sort of
shifted his view
to a you know a cyclic cosmology one
that repeats in time
what's your view well okay i
i uh uh i mean
paul's objections as far as i understand
them are basically phenomenological he
thinks the theory doesn't doesn't
really uh fit quite
but also the uh you know the multiverse
as a natural outcome
i think is a thing that really turned
away from inflation
yeah uh yeah i it doesn't bother me
uh they uh it could be it's
it's kind of uh it's another lesson in
humility perhaps for fundamental physics
we might not be able to predict as much
as we had hoped
uh about the basic laws we might have to
leave some parameters
uh as historical accidents or something
but but i
that i try to resist because that's the
easy way out you know you
you know that's that's just a convenient
excuse if you're
saying oh i i failed therefore it's a
failure principle
so but but it could be that way it's
certainly logically possible that
some of the things we think of as
fundamental constants are
historically conditioned and are
different elsewhere yeah
it's certainly very logical possibility
uh
so we'll just have to see how well what
if it's the king of players develop
uh one point let me ask one question
though if it's the case that
the um the breadth of the multiverse is
so broad
that any measurement would find a home
in some
multiverse i mean this is the issue that
paul said and he says you know then then
we're in a room that's just not
the cmb you know that's that's not true
i mean you know we have
we have our core theory we have our
standard model
and uh you know and
it's not a random it makes many
predictions so it's
it's highly over determined it's not so
our description of the world is
definitely not underdetermined we have
plenty we have lots and lots of data
so uh and and whether you whether it
takes
we ideally we'd like to have a one
parameter theory or zero parameter
theory of everything
of the fundamental or at least the
fundamental laws and excuses for why
the complex world we see around us uh
is is complex uh
but and then we shouldn't aspire to
incorporate it in the fundamental laws
in detail uh but uh
you know whether in
in a way whether we need to use one
parameter two parameters or five
parameters or 20 parameters
yeah look that that that's that's to me
is a higher order question but i
i think to say that that we can't
predict anything is ridiculous i mean
right we do a lot
so
advocate there is an assumption of
simplicity in that because you take the
core theory the standard model
there are a lot of zeros in there that
we are assuming from simplicity we don't
even
pay attention to those zeros other
fields other couplings you know
so if you allow yeah but but
yeah but but uh
their principles we're trying to we're
trying
to me the goal the goal of science is to
describe
the world uh and we're describing the
world very very well and it's not
underdetermined
i i i make the same argument too of
course you know what we do is
you know we make our best understanding
of the phenomena that we see and then we
modify it in the smallest possible way
when some anomaly comes along we have to
describe it as well and yeah and we use
it i mean this
this is the basic procedure that
uh was articulated by by newton and
brilliantly exemplified by him and that
we've been following ever since
which is analysis and synthesis you try
to understand
very basic principles by boiling seeing
them in the simplest possible way
they operate and then build back up by
deduction
yeah that's been spectacularly
successful
for sure uh and i don't see any reason
to uh pooh-pooh it would say that
and and uh yeah
how should i say it
it's not our job to describe
all possible worlds whatever that means
is our primary job is to describe our
world and
the the the the the logical
possibilities that aren't realized in
our world
well that's curious but it's not really
the job
or what's to me at least it's not really
the job of
fundamental science to uh to explain
that
black hole information problem another
one of those
arenas of tension yeah
do you think it's where do you think we
are on that
i it's
complicated i guess the uh i think
you know one of the i was alluding
previously to making to
using these griffiths type models i've
recently made progress not on
understanding black holes but on
understand understanding uh
uh lumps of coal
so how a pure quantum system can radiate
can in that case a burn you put in a
highly excited state it burns the
radiation looks thermal and so
but we of course we know and it goes
down to a ground state
the the radiation despite looking
thermal perhaps for a very long time is
actually not thermal
how can that be why and i i think i have
a very
clear understanding of that the case of
standard quantum mechanical systems
now black holes have additional
constraints about
how things are arranged in space time
and how you transmit information
causally
that you know it's hard to resolve and
we don't have a lot of experimental
data to go on we it's not clear that if
we had a correct theory we'd even know
that it was very happy you know i mean
but uh i
i guess uh it's a fun problem it's not
clear to me that it's a really central
problem in describing the world
right and i the way the inspiration i
took from it was to try to understand
uh not black holes but things that
have the sort of most basic
things in common that they we
uh that they they radiate in ways that
can look thermal for a long time and yet
have to be pure states
how does that happen right right as far
as i'm
i don't think there's any really deep
mystery there but to see it
concretely is was a challenge and
continues to be yeah all right so um
that was sort of the bulk of things that
i wanted to talk about
though you know a lot of students watch
these conversations
that we've been having some young you
know some
graduate students some younger you know
and we've even had people
write that their their child five six
years old sort of watches these
conversations just to let the ideas wash
over them
so do we yeah i recommend that actually
i mean it meant a lot to me
well i don't think well even at five or
six i was a big admirer of einstein and
you know it was immersed in the cold war
and people were talking about advanced
weapons and you know it was pretty
scary of course but but the fact that
that people were controlling nature and
could
produce these spectacular effects i was
immersed in that of course i didn't
understand it but but just knowing that
it's out there in this sense of
excitement and possibility
and base rate you know people going into
space and
yeah just to be exposed to it is great
and then
you can fill in the details later but an
important part of filling in the details
is you need patience
because it's unusual material it's
difficult
[Music]
and to to have that patience it really
helps to have the motivation and to see
the goal
yeah i was i was going to ask you if you
had any words of wisdom for those
students but you basically answered my
question before i
i even asked it so yeah that is
an inspiring outlook that there is so
much more to learn and
it's a yeah definitely uh
cast a wide net uh don't insist on it
understanding ever don't insist on
understanding everything before you
understand anything
uh and uh but at the same time
the complementary advice i would give is
pay attention to the foundations do
do learn your calculus and so forth as
soon as possible
and you know learn how to converse with
a computer
now and just be curious and have fun
find out what you love
yeah and go there absolutely so
everybody
you know this is uh frank's new book let
me try to center it in the frame there
fundamentals 10 keys to reality just
came out three days ago
there's an even better image that you
see on your screen right there
so you know you should go get it it's a
beautifully written account
that really allows you to see the world
through the eyes of
one of the great physicists of our age
and gives a different perspective on on
how we can engage with reality so
you should get it read it enjoy it
re-read it and frank wilcheck saying
thank you so much for joining us okay
all right everybody that was our
conversation with frank
wilczyk nobel laureate for his work
in quantum chromo dynamics and as you've
seen
you know he's a very broad thinker who
is concerned much more
than the details much more with how we
human beings
can relate to the world in a way that's
exciting creative can even involve
contradictory perspectives but that's
the beauty of having a human brain
the ability to engage with the world in
a fundamentally
human manner so before we wrap up let me
um
see if there are any particular
questions that you guys have in the chat
i'm looking
over at it here and uh
let's see uh yeah so elsa
notes never forget when you're looking
in the sky you're looking in the past
elsa that's true both scientifically and
it's a very poetic
idea i like to think that everything
that happens
on planet earth right the
reflected light rays
from planet earth they race across the
universe and carry
our present out to the cosmos
it's a kind of immortality in a way the
fact that something happens in the
universe
gives off light and the light from that
event
has an imprint of that event and that
imprint just
travels until obviously it reaches
some destination if not it just can
travel
through the cosmos indefinitely which is
a kind of an exciting
way of thinking about how the world is
susan roy asks when you use the word
information what precisely
do you mean
it's not an easy question to answer
susan it's a vital
question to ask to some extent when we
talk about information we're talking
about the data necessary to specify a
physical system
that would be the most straightforward
definition i could give so for instance
when we're talking about air in this
room where i
am right now there is a certain amount
of information
required to nail down the precise
positions and velocities in the
classical language of the particles
or the precise quantum state of the
particles using the quantum mechanical
language and that would be the
information content of the air
inside this room and when we talk about
entropy
entropy arises when
we don't look at the detailed microstate
of say the particles of air in this room
but rather we
summarize their state with more
coarse macroscopic features like the
temperature
of the molecules and the pressure and
the volume
of space that the molecules fill and the
number of molecules those
more macroscopic qualities don't
give us the detailed microscopic
information so we often think about
entropy as the amount of hidden
information
where the hidden information is the
information necessary to specify the
detailed microstate
of say the particles of gas in this room
so that's one answer
but in different contexts the notion of
information can take on
somewhat different form so the answer
to the question susan is somewhat
context
dependent but that would be an answer
that
is quite relevant when we're thinking
about the world
in the language of statistical mechanics
thermodynamics
and using the concept of
entropy rob b asks can the universe be
cyclic
just by the direction of time not
exactly what you mean by
just by the direction of time but when
people talk about
a cyclic universe it's usually one that
in one form or another
goes through some sort of origin event
origin like event a big bang like event
develops evolves for some period of time
and then
somehow finds its back finds itself back
in a configuration
that yields an event analogous to the
original creation event some new kind of
big bang
event so there was this expirotic
scenario that was developed in the
context of string theory where these
large
membranes three-dimensional membranes
could float through a higher dimensional
space
slam into each other every trillion
years or so and that
slamming together would be the big
bang-like conflagration that would start
the cycle
anew there's an older idea going way
back to the early days of general
relativity
as richard thoman was developing these
ideas where the universe would have a
big bang it would expand for a while
reach a maximum size and then come back
in on itself
collapse back down and then the cycle
would happen
repeatedly that particular model had
problems in dealing with the second law
of thermodynamics because
in that case the buildup of entropy
would
strongly suggest that the sequence
of big bangs and big crunches couldn't
go on forever so there'd have to be some
initial event and therefore the cycles
couldn't go on
forever but others in the more modern
incarnation of these ideas like paul
steinhardt
working with people like neil turock and
and others early days
uh bert overt also postdoc of mine at
columbia justin curry
had early models of this they've
developed versions of the cyclic
scenario
that seemingly can go on forever and
still not have an issue with the second
law of thermodynamics not everybody
agrees with
that those models actually make sense
you may recall in our conversation with
lenny suskind
lenny was definitely no it doesn't work
you know that's like a perpetual motion
machine
so i i'm not going to get into the fray
on those particular arguments i
understand the arguments from both sides
but that is what we would mean by
a cyclic universe all right we're
heading on now to uh
two hours now i'm a little exhausted you
probably are as well
um some interesting questions here
liam what is the relation between
symmetry breaking in the standard model
where does it break
so symmetry breaking really should be
thought of as symmetry hiding
i'll end on this i think so the idea is
that if you have certain mathematical
equations that
enjoy a certain kind of symmetry when
you change around the symbols according
to some
rule of transformation the resulting
equations
are unchanged that's what we mean by the
standard model have
certain symmetries it has a symmetry
that has a name su 3 costs su 2
cross u 1. these are not a billion and a
billion gauge
symmetries that the equations of the
standard model enjoy
when we say that this image is broken we
don't mean that the equations somehow
are
changed rather we envision applying
those equations
in an environment in a world and that
world
environment has qualities that do not
respect
the symmetry transformation and that's
where the symmetry is broken it's an
environmental fact an environmental
quality that doesn't respect the
symmetry that the fundamental equations
do
so the equations have the symmetry but
the symmetry becomes hidden
by the qualities of the environment for
instance the environment may be threaded
by a higgs field
and that higgs field may have the
property that it doesn't respect
certain symmetry transformations and
that's why the symmetry becomes
hidden or in the language of the field
it becomes broken and that's vital
to the standard model of particle
physics the core theory that frank was
talking about
and it's one of the the vital ideas in
our understanding
of the physical universe all right i
think that's it for us
here today thanks for tuning in
we will probably have another one of
these sessions we seem to be doing them
on a rhythm of
every two weeks we do look at your
suggestions keep them coming for people
that
you would like to hear from frank was
one of the suggestions and you see that
we now had a conversation with him
uh there are other interesting folks out
there in the world some nobel prize
winners some not noble prize winners
just
interest thinkers across the board send
in your thoughts of who you'd like
us to have that conversation about and
we will
join again in roughly two weeks again
you should sign up for the
world science festival newsletter so you
can be alerted when these sessions
happen
you can follow the world science
festival on the usual social channels
twitter and facebook and you can follow
me on twitter as well i'm at begreen
on twitter you join in i announce these
sessions there as
other tidbits of science and i also i'm
starting to use facebook a little bit
more
i kind of let it go for a while we'll
see
but i also am b green or brian green
at facebook okay look forward to seeing
you
next time bye
[Music]
you